hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play parasite now
it's been a while since I did just a uh
it's sort of I hear that over there you
can't tell me I don't okay it's been a
while since I just played a random any
horror game but to be honest there
haven't been that many that looked good
but this one actually did so I'm gonna
give it a try
wh d remove mouse to look mouse wheel
for light mouse wheel for light oh I get
it I can oh oh well that's much better I
can actually see and then right click to
use chalk 1 2 3 also light oh I get it
four different light levels anyway so
basically I'm in a sewer of some sort oh
that was good right click gosh oh I
guess that might be useful for helping
navigate through here because I am gonna
get lost it's kind of like the idea of
dropping glow sticks I guess except this
is much more sensible someone actually
thought with their brain okay so I'm in
the stores but you guys know them I
don't particularly like sewers but it's
a cat shed its attracted to light well
that's not good what's attracted to
light what is attracted to light it's
kind of a sort of an amnesia mechanic
where I got a little lantern here and we
can turn it out if I want to or get it
real dim what's going on here well I'm
gonna be hitting the old dusty trail of
goddamn sewers which I hate
I got a wonder just how many
horrifically happened in sewers I don't
hear many haunted stories about
stewart's mostly just about houses oh oh
oh this looks familiar
Oh fantastic how about no how about no
it's all too reminiscent of vanish just
like my least favorite game ever
at least hopefully this one won't be
randomized
I hear this constant gurgling which I'm
assuming is oh god okay I just got a
chill down my spine because back in
vanish if I hit a dead end there might
be a monster behind me did you hear that
okay I'm assuming that gurgling is just
pipes filled with blood gushing through
the sewer drains okay so there's a block
double if it's there can't go that way
what is this least I actually have a
light source unlike in vanish but I
still don't know what it is and why it
would be attracted to light this is
probably why I need to put down chalk
because otherwise I'm going to get lost
around here this is probably not a good
what you can't do that to me god it's
just eyes what happened is that the end
of the game ah you gave me a heart
attack what did I do
it popped up out of nowhere well I guess
that's it then Jesus all right let me
try it again be right back okay we're
back in sorry about that guys I didn't
understand that the enemy would be a
giant son of a [ __ ] who was attracted
to light up here I didn't even have time
to run away that was the douchey I can't
even run I have no sprint capabilities
okay it's attracted to light fantastic
but what does that mean for me go I just
have to walk through this area with no
light then what's the point of even
having it fine you know what I don't
care that's what I'm gonna have to do
I'm gonna draw the chalk everywhere I go
oh I don't like the fact that it just
came out of freaking nowhere getting
light Oh can't see oh this is like the
worst trade off I don't want to do this
I don't want to trade off my light for
maybe the possibility of damnit the
possibility of damnit I Steve I see
something in the distance over there
come on I just oh it's dark I can't see
ah God yeah I can't see anything
what is this ah is this I just was this
exists
what is it stay the it the rats - are
afraid what does that even supposed to
mean does that mean you dick was running
these messages in black smudge someone
rubbed their poop all over the walls
that what happened Oh dark I gotta get
light it's got a gimme it's going all
right
oh it's gonna get me I know it's gonna
get me they got too much light what
okay but that dough I'm just gonna walk
back with nothing gonna happen to me
how's it gonna happen to me okay I think
I see something did that open one of
these grates
no no what was the point of that huh why
did I need to do that yeah what he's
hitting [ __ ] games that I play they
have an exit they have an end of the
game but I don't know what it is so well
nor do I care I wrote an X there I
thought I did oh oh this way oh it's
probably a bad way probably bad way to
get high a bad way to go oh this is
loops back to this one okay so this is
like a maze all right yeah let me mark
that run that way no this just loops
back again this might be I'm assuming
this actually is randomly generated oh
this is loops back what the hell I got
nowhere to go you son of a [ __ ] what
was that switched for what is switched
oh I'm so conflicted all right whatever
hey I'm gonna go back maybe there was
something I don't know I don't even know
anymore I don't even know anymore I pull
the lever and the lever did something
what it did I got no damn idea okay
there's two more ways to go let's go Oh
mr. white eyes don't come popping out to
me pull the lever
oh no Manama not too much like just
enough light to see just enough light
oh I thought eyes our white flow huh I
see the CEO I stare oh it's time right
don't go that way don't go that way that
way is yeah and mayhem and destruction
let's go this way
oh this is a pair of white eyes I don't
even know I'm afraid of it it's like the
laziest laziest monster that could ever
live lazy I probably shouldn't be
insulting the monsters I'm kinda I get
it
I'll admit I played worst game oh crap
okay this is a dead end I like this
chalk this is a chalk is a good idea why
don't other people think of this in war
games chalk great brilliant idea totally
reusable doesn't run out even a remotely
quickly damn enough Kong's way oh I
gotta go down that way with the eyeballs
I just got to not have my light out
that's what I gotta do uh
where'd he go I don't see him anymore I
don't see him anymore
what was it he knows I lose him anymore
oh it's a goat baby that's a baby goat
Oh what did I do
come on come on my god what happened oh
oh you got me you son of a [ __ ] Scott
damn it I fudgesicles all right Wow this
is stupid okay they need to fix that
goddamn it okay I'm I don't know how to
beat this alright anyway I'm gonna end
this here because I don't know what's
going on it's it's got a solid premise
but it needs to work on some mechanics
of it I like I like the trolling around
and sewers especially with the chalk in
the and the thing it's pretty good but
it could use some work on the month
anyway you guys try for yourself link to
the downloads in the description below
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
yeah
oh cool idea but going
Green I have to like it
strong do what they
and the weave supper why
oh man
fact I gotta say a feast of bodies